what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
morning coffee thoughts for I give my
thoughts over morning coffee before I
start don't forget to subscribe to the
channel ring that notification Bell that
way you're going to be notified of my
daily videos like the video on your way
in let's get started so today
I want to talk about why the tribe cons
leave women lead women down a path of
Destruction I will say I have had
management to tell me to stop harping on
this topic Pearl bring people together
you want to have a broader appeal
broader audience
but I just don't care I just really I
don't care because I think that we
should fight for truth and we should
fight for being honest and true now guys
when I started my journey I really had
it more tradcon mindset that was like my
I would say beginning I watched Jordan
Peterson I watched Ben Shapiro et cetera
Etc
but the issue with a lot of trout counts
they're definitely better than the libs
all right let's just better than the
libs but they default to egalitarianism
they tell women we're more special than
we are and
um they they're very big into the not
all women not all
okay so to begin this we have to accept
that attention is to women as sex is to
men now how do we come also if you're
breathing that is my my dog now how do I
come to this conclusion you're not going
to follow me at all if we don't come to
this occlusion conclusion how do women's
egos get like built right
um we want to be attractive like we want
men to find us beautiful
men don't really care if we find them
attractive like it's a bonus but if they
don't get the sex at the end of it
it's like nothing to them that's why you
see the men bragging about who they
slept with and you see the women
bragging about who's in their DMS right
they're completely different and I took
this a step further
and I said if you ask most women if you
could be eternally youthful beautiful
have a perfect body perfect face for a
lifetime but you have no sex
or you could have sex with the hottest
man on the planet but he doesn't really
find you attractive
um because you're an ugly old hag for a
lifetime you're stuck at that most women
would pick the beauty I would pick the
beauty most women are going to pick the
beauty because beauty is power to women
now what is male attention
male attention and validation is
Instagram likes it is dating apps I mean
why do you think women we have these
dating apps never meet up with the guys
it's because we like the attention and
the validation
um why do women wear makeup it's for
attention and validation it's you know I
put on eyeliner today draws attention to
I got I got green eyes you know give me
attention just kidding but um so you
have to understand imagine a 12 year old
a 12 year old boy is given unlimited sex
like he's just given her 13 14 a young
boy is given on like just crazy amounts
of hookers hot women that he can just
sleep with from a really young age that
would be really damaging and you have to
understand that women today we are very
much damaged I'm not saying I'm above it
I'm not saying I'm better but we have
all had crazy amounts of attention given
to us from the time we were really young
some of us got social media at like 13
14 years old and that was damaging
because it makes us think we're more
important and more special than we are
because from the time we're 13 14 years
old
um all right let's let's just go to 16
to make this or 18 whatever whatever you
want to do okay
um
because I don't want people giving their
certain accusations I don't need those
accusations so all right 18 years old
you get you can get wrappers in your DMs
you can get basketball players in your
DMs you can get business Executives in
your DMs you can get the top one percent
men in your DMs at 18 years old even if
that's not the case for you because a
lot of women will say and you know I've
done this before because I'm like what
the [__] I was never invited I know
Yachts you guys were getting invited on
yachts
I was like what who where were these
Yachts right you know it might just be
the best guy in your hometown it might
just be the best guy in the city but the
point is men oh [__] men out of your
league out of our leagues have been
hitting on us from a young age
so we're all just very much attention
addicted we have male friends we have
male co-workers that give us attention
we have
um social media that gives us attention
okay are we on the same wavelength guys
all right attention is to women as to
Sexes to men so when I say cheating is
different for men and for women the
equivalent you know when a woman cheats
it I would argue it's more getting
attention from Men and oftentimes guys
we they can kind of work through it like
I wouldn't say end of marriage because
she flirted with a guy I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry red pill guys I'm sorry
but I wouldn't say end of marriage
because she posts one provocative
picture on Instagram
flirts with the guy at the store right
um the same way I wouldn't say end the
marriage if he [__] a stripper you know
these are the same things because we
both get validation from them like
there's something that makes us like
feel good as women about getting
attention from men and there's something
about that makes the men feel good
um about getting attention from our
getting the sex from women
um and so the Trad cons will come in and
say well a high value man shouldn't
cheat or a high value men don't cheat
they're not high value if they cheat why
aren't you guys why aren't you guys
pushed to like wave their fingers and be
like why aren't you guys pushing
monogamy and my my um
trade-off is I'm really not going to
take those guys seriously until they say
one only married virgins and two until
they really start shaming
um the way females are acting because
even trabcon women posting their faces
on Instagram which gives them validation
from other men right and I'm not guys
just you know this isn't a hate this
isn't like oh judge them they're bad
people what up no no no no no no I'm no
better you're no better nobody's better
than anybody the point is the double
standard where these women are actively
getting attention from other men
constantly
um maybe they're not dressing the most
provocatively but you you know
men are always going to look they're
look you see what I'm saying so it's
like we have these open Instagrams with
selfies on them we have these male
friends around them and you know you
historically you would have just gotten
the attention from your husband okay are
we on the same wavelength now the men
have adapted and they just deal with
this but the point is this isn't ideal
and the men put up with a lot from us
why is it crazy for us to put up with
some stuff from them and I think that
should be and I think that message is a
bit more humble
and a bit more honest
um
okay the other thing I noticed that the
Trad cons do
um I'll give you an example so my friend
had a tweet about my friend Rachel had a
tweet and a bunch of tribe called women
had a tweet saying my husband does not
help with chores
and what is the gut reaction from the
Trad cons
well I mean if he loves you he's gonna
he's gonna help you with the chores so
now it's like a shaming tactic where
those husbands don't care or love their
wives enough well and it's like a guy I
know the gut reaction because all those
women and men
um have been lied to and again they
default to egalitarianism so whenever we
we go towards well I do this he does
that we have our roles
the women come in and say well you don't
have to and and the thing is what's what
makes relationships easier when people
have roles is there's less spite in my
opinion you know I mean I I had a grown
man come on my show and argue that
people should get divorced over chores
but if you have man chores and women
chores there's no
oh he needs to help me more he needs to
do more because that's your role that's
his role he doesn't have to change the
diapers now I'm not saying there's no
middle ground ever but the problem with
women is we just have a nature and
we just have this nature to never be
happy so unfortunately it's never going
to be good enough for us and I think
that
is the issue is the trade cons don't
acknowledge female nature and the red
pill isn't as nice to hear it's really
not um it kind of hurts hurts your
feelings as a chick at first you're like
God damn but it's a lot more honest so
I'll give you an example women tend to
leave low value men for high value men
and what the Trad cons will do
is come in and say not all women are
like that
well you can find a good woman
well then we have to Define what a good
woman is and they won't say that it's a
virgin
because the least likely woman to leave
is a virgin however however I will argue
the virgins of today are not the virgins
of yesterday because the virgins are
going to have such a line behind them to
date them
um that they kind of come to the same
problem where their egos get inflated
and they get overloaded on attention
like imagine you know Dan Bulgarian or
whatever whatever his name is that that
level of attention from the time he's a
young boy would make it very difficult
later in life now the ideal obviously is
two virgins but what the tracons will do
is when I say why don't you tell the men
to demand virgins as they say well
shouldn't the men be virgins too when
deep down we know that virginity is
different for men and for women we know
that it is much worse for a woman to not
be a virgin than a man to not be a
virgin yet the Trap cons instead of
being honest default to egalitarianism
and sort of waste time like they just
waste my time because they try to act
like cheating is the same for men and
for women when we know it's not they try
to act like virginity and promiscuity is
the same for men and for women when we
know it's not
um
and as women we can't improve because
you guys are too busy coddling us and I
think as women we need to
we need to stop with the
we need to sorry guys we need to kind of
get mad that all these guys are
pandering and Catering to us
um another example I can think of is
when I said 25 year old women are hotter
than 35 year old women and there was an
army of simps that came after me
um they they said okay well you're not
married you can't and this is this is
how you can tell they're triggered and
this is how you can also tell that the
tradcon wives
um you can tell that their ego is very
invested in their beauty rather than
their family when they're coming at me
for pointing out the obvious like the
literal obvious this used to be common
sense but the problem is the Sims and
the media the culture the filters the
botox the all this [__] has gassed up
our ego so much that we all think we're
more important and we're more special
than we really are
now
the 25 year old women are hotter than 35
year old women
um I had an army of Sims saying well my
wife is hot my wife is this this this
old and I have oh well don't worry the
men get wife goggles
really
really and this is what I mean like
you're telling me a 25 year old chick I
could give you if we took the ages off
if we took the ages off
25 year old women I'll give you 10 and
35 year old women I'd give you 10.
even your wife let's let's take off
and and I would give it to men okay I I
don't want to do this because that
doesn't mean too much of an [__] but
I'm like okay these pictures that were
tweeted at me I could give them 25 year
old women and 35 year old women and all
the men would take the 25 year old women
and this is the problem is these and the
reason I call out the trade cons is
because it's very confusing to the
younger women when you have all of these
wives where their ego was super invested
in their looks they pretend to be these
traditional wives when we can clearly I
mean the men can clearly see that
they're not but the women we just
believe anything when you know
traditional wives really do get married
before 25.
that was the most important thing to
them I'm not saying it's me and I'm
honest about that the difference is we
have all these women playing pretend and
the men are letting us they're letting
us believe we're just as hot as in our
30s and our 20s they're letting us
believe that
we
um get these wife goggles and our men
just find us hot even when we're 65
really
really come on come on guys I'm not
saying we can't be cute but it's like we
at some point guys have to tell us the
truth and that and men are repulsed by
the fact that we are not virgins okay
and the exchange of value that we have
so we have what men bring and what women
are supposed to bring okay men are
supposed to protect
provide
women are supposed to bring purity
youth
children
so so protect provide
I'm trying to remember what else but
okay these are the Bare Bones right man
traditional men protect and provide
women were not bringing the Purity
anymore that's what that's why I harp so
hard on on The Virginity because that's
in a marriage you're supposed to wear
white the men doesn't don't wear white
the women wear white that's part of the
exchange youth youth
um if you're over 25 and you got married
you didn't bring you sorry he would have
been considered expired and I'm over 25
right and that's okay and that's the
thing like when we acknowledge hey
that's the ideal it it could humble you
a little bit and be like all right I'm
not the ideal right but you know we can
work to be more like the ideal now
unfortunately for women
you know um I guess we'd add femininity
whatever there's other stuff right
unfortunately for women a lot of stuff
we can't get back we can't get back
youth we can't get back to Purity right
um but
you know sometimes the NBA right the NBA
has All-Stars they have Pro players and
sometimes by the time they figure out
the best coaching
you know their time has passed but at
least you can be honest to the younger
women but all these Trad I'm just so
tired of the egalitarianism and I'm so
tired of the La La Land the Lala I'm
just tired of the delusion so the men
protect and provide right most men make
more than women okay and this idea if
women we go out into the workforce and
we get jobs let's stop whining that the
men don't make more because honestly in
this day and age men are discouraged and
I just talked to a recruiter yesterday
men are discriminated against for a lot
of high paying jobs a lot are are they
actively do not hire men so we chose to
go to work now all these egalitarian
pushing women's Business leadership all
that [__]
um are pushing women to take their jobs
and then we whine that they're not
providing when really that was our
choice and again protection most men are
stronger than the average woman
no
a lot of times what they'll say is the
men aren't masculine today well the
women aren't feminine but we always
point at the men for not being masculine
enough
when the women
um typically we aren't feminine enough
and the thing about masculinity I really
think if there was men's spaces where
men could just like Bully each other
they really would become more masculine
but women on the other hand once our
femininity is gone
um it really is lost like
I I am I I don't see many women that
really come back from getting super
masculine I just don't see it I see a
lot of women playing pretend but like
when push comes to shove it always comes
out
um so I really am trying to push and
encourage tradcon women and men to be a
bit more honest because I just think we
need to live in a world where people are
honest
um and I think I would have been in a
better place if people were honest with
me and I think younger women will be in
a better place if people are honest with
them and the thing is we have all of
these wives with these big Egos and we
saw that we saw that these traditional
wives getting mad that I'm I'm talking
about you're hotter when you're younger
traditional wives and if I point out if
they tweet pictures at me of themselves
and I point out they were hotter when
they were younger than I'm the bad guy
even though this is common sense our
grandmas would show us pictures when
they were younger and be like I was a
hottie you know like like this is was
keyword was but we have all these wives
with like these big egos that are rooted
in their looks and you see this by them
purchasing Botox
fake hair fake nails and I'm I'm I don't
have a problem with a little bit of that
but guys this is getting out of control
this is getting crazy you you uh now are
people tattooing makeup that's what
someone told me people are tattooing
makeup now I'm like this is crazy
um and that's what I mean their ego is
more invested in themselves and their
social media than it is in their
children
and this is the modern world so I really
just want to encourage
the Trad cons to be more honest because
I think if they were more honest
I I think we could get farther with
these conversations if every time we
talk about women it could just stay on
the women before we say butt net because
sorry cheating not equal chores not
equal
all that stuff it's not equal so let me
know what you guys think in the comments
um like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel and I'll talk
to you next time